OUR GOVERNMENT’S INVOLVEMENT IN
FUNDING THIS RESEARCH.
>> Harris: RONNA McDANIEL RNC
CHAIR JOINS ME NOW.
WHY IS THIS SO DIFFICULT?
WE’RE LOOKING AT SOMETHING THAT
WE KNOW IS NOT RIGHT.
WE’RE DEALING WITH A COMMUNIST
COUNTRY WHO WAS NOT FORTHRIGHT,
HONEST AND TRANSPARENT AT THE
VERY BEGINNING OF THE PANDEMIC.
>> YOU THINK OF HOW MANY LIVES
LOST, HOW MANY OF US HAVE LOST
LOVED ONES AND FRIENDS AND TO
SEE THIS COVER-UP BEING AIDED
BY THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION FOR
THEM TO SHUT DOWN A CREDIBLE
INVESTIGATION TO GO TO THE
W.H.O. WHO WAS SO INEFFECTIVE
FROM THE VERY BEGINNING IN
IDENTIFYING THIS PANDEMIC AND
ALSO THEY HAVE HAD A YEAR TO
INVESTIGATE.
THEY HAVEN’T.
I THINK IT’S SHAMEFUL AND I
AGREE WITH RAND PAUL.
WE NEED TO GET TO THE BOTTOM OF
THIS BUT I DON’T KNOW IF THIS
IS THE ADMINISTRATION THAT CAN
DO THAT.
THEY’RE PART OF THE COVER-UP
RIGHT NOW.
>> Harris: I’LL MOVE TO THIS.
THE REPUBLICAN GOVERNORS
ASSOCIATION IS POINTING A
FINGER AT MICHIGAN DEMOCRAT
GRETCHEN WHITMER FOR VIOLATING
HER OWN COVID RESTRICTIONS
AGAIN.
THIS TIME SHE TOOK A SECRET
FLIGHT TO FLORIDA WHILE
RESIDENTS OF HER STATE WERE
LOCKED DOWN UNDER PANDEMIC
TRAVEL ADVISORIES.
THE ASSOCIATION IS TAKING AIM
AT WHITMER IN A NEW AD.
HERE IT IS.
>> GRETCHEN WHITMER SECRETLY
FLEW TO FLORIDA TO VISIT HER
FATHER.
I WISH I HAD THAT SAME CHANCE.
BUT WHITMER CLOSED NURSING
HOMES WHEN WE TRIED TO SAY
GOODBYE THE DAY HE DIED THE
FACILITY CALLED THE POLICE.
WHITMER IGNORED HER OWN RULES
WHILE THE REST OF US WERE
FORCED TO COMPLY.
>> Harris: WHAT ARE YOUR
REACTION TO THAT
>> MY HEART ACHES FOR THAT
FAMILY AND FOR SO MANY FAMILIES
WHO CAN’T GET ANSWERS FROM THE
WHITMER ADMINISTRATION WITH
WHAT HAPPENED AT THE NURSING
HOMES BUT THE  HYPOCRISY FOR
HER SAYING YOU CAN’T SEE YOUR
LOVED ONES AND HER TAKING A
PRIVATE PLAY AND SHOWS WHY SHE
WILL HAVE A TOUGH REELECTION
NEXT YEAR.
WE’LL CHANGE THAT GOVERNORSHIP
TO REPUBLICAN BECAUSE OF THE
MANY FAILURES AND HYPOCRISY OF
WHITMER IN MICHIGAN.
>> Harris: LOOK.
I WILL STATE IN NEW JERSEY
GOVERNOR MURPHY DID THE SAME
THING.
WE DIDN’T HAVE THE CARNAGE IN
NURSING HOMES THAT THEY DID IN
NEW YORK CITY AND YOU HAVE
WHITMER.
>> SHE IS NOT BEING FORTHCOMING.
YOU CAN’T GET THE NURSING HOME
DATA OUT OF MICHIGAN.
SHE COVERED UP EVERYTHING WITH
NDAs AND LETTING PEOPLE GO.
THERE IS A LOT HERE IN MICHIGAN
THE CITIZENS DON’T KNOW BECAUSE
OF A GOVERNOR WHO HASN’T LED
AND HIDING AND COVERING UP HER
TRACKS.
>> Harris: CHAIRWOMAN RONNA